I didn't want to play Christopher Reeve
and break my neck so I wanted this horse
to be relaxed you don't you don't want
to I don't know what these people have
against facts Christopher Reeves
Christopher Reeve got on a horse he fell
off and he broke his neck and then
considered himself lucky because he went
on awards show smiling and I found that
so like and it was like God only
challenges those that can accept it
because if that was me I would have just
kept driving right off the edge
I would have just I would have pretended
I was cool with it like yeah that's
fantastic just being ahead you know and
then just waiting
hey take me down to the pier
I love this I miss the spell of sea salt
and then once they got me
those [__] things I would go right
over like [__] OJ and the Naked Gun
up the upper deck that was a good movie
you better not challenge me because he's
gonna be horribly disappointed
with the outcome